we've been recently contacted by a
source that has insider information
with what apple is doing with their
higher end apple silicon max
including both the high-end imac and the
mac pro
and based on what this source has told
us we can finally put a ton of puzzle
pieces together
including some recent leaks and reports
from reputable sources
like mark german to nail down both the
release date
and various specs and features of the
high-end imac
so let's get right into it the main
piece of info our source gave us is that
there will not be
an imac pro or a very expensive imac
the source said that apple is
constraining how far they take the imac
based on a 2 000 retail consumer price
target
which is similar to the current 27-inch
imax price
the reason for that is that apple wants
to be more consumer-focused for their
apple silicon max
lowering the prices compared to how
expensive the old intel models could be
configured
the main reason is that when it comes to
the mac most people buy the lower end
max
since they're much easier to afford a
smaller percentage would go for the 16
inch macbook pro
and 27 inch imac and an even smaller
percentage
would go for the intel based imac pro
and then an
even smaller percentage of people would
spec them out
with the highest end intel chips so the
source is basically saying that the now
discontinued imac pro
is dead with no more refresh expected to
come
and if you think about it the m1 max
have basically proven to apple
and the world that going for lower entry
level prices
with apple silicon was enough to cause
max sales to absolutely skyrocket
and break records in terms of sales even
though
all of those new macs share just a
single
m1 chat so because of that successful
strategy
the mac lineup including the high-end
imac will now be more consumer focused
and the source says that the new smaller
apple silicon mac pro
will basically be there as the high-end
customizable option for the heavy
professionals out there
and interestingly the source claims that
even the mac pro will see
a huge price decrease starting somewhere
at around
3 000 plus dollars at the base price
which is half the price of the current
intel mac pro
and it's all due to apple saving tons of
cash by using their own
apple design chips instead of paying
intel for cpus
and amd for discrete gpus that right
there is also another reason why the
imac pro
isn't coming back there just isn't
enough of a gap
between the 2 000 imac and the 3 000
mac pro to warrant an imac pro to fit in
between
those price points now moving on i fully
believe that the high-end imac will for
sure
have a chin just like the 24 inch imac
for a few different reasons first off
the larger imac has
always looked exactly like the lower end
models in the past
so it makes total sense for the upcoming
larger imac
to match the 24 inch imac in terms of
the design
which will allow apple to use these
side-by-side marketing images
of both imac sizes now don't worry the
chin
doesn't necessarily mean that it's going
to look bad because
even if the chin is the same height as
on the 24 inch imac
the larger display size on the high-end
version will actually make it look
much slimmer on the larger imac display
as you can see in this image that i drew
up in photoshop and on top of that i can
also guarantee that apple will be able
to fit the entire logic
board into the chin area just like
they're already doing with the 24 inch
imac
because increasing the display size will
allow them to increase
the thickness of the mac itself by
around 25 percent
to help fit a thicker logic board all
while keeping the relative dimensions
looking proper and balanced compared to
the 24
inch model and if you think about it a
larger display would mean that the chin
itself
would become significantly longer giving
apple even more room
for a longer logic board so based on all
of that
it honestly really just makes sense to
keep the chin around
on the high-end imac to keep the design
language the same
between both sizes since apple has
always done that in the past
and for that same reason i can basically
guarantee that the larger imac will have
white bezels just like the current 24
inch model
the main reason is that many buyers of
the 24 inch imac
have been pleasantly surprised by how
well the white bezels blend
into light or white colored walls
actually being much less distracting
than the current black bezels and then
if you add in the fact that the bezels
will look even slimmer
and less noticeable on the high-end imac
because of the larger display
it makes total sense for the bezels to
be white and now before i get into the
interesting details about the apple
silicon chip specs and release date
i want to get into the actual display
size of the imac
itself i can 100 guarantee that the imac
will not
have a 32 inch display because that
would make the imac
larger than the 32 inch pro display xdr
which makes no sense at all on top of
that our source says that the cost of
taking the imac
to a 30 inch or larger display would
push the price
beyond apple's 2 000 retail price target
for the imac
so it needs to stay under 30 inches my
source also believes that apple is
working on a cheaper
external display which will not use many
led technology like the pro display xdr
with a price target of around twelve
hundred dollars
and if you didn't already know this
apple's 27 inch imac
uses the same exact panel as lg's
ultrafine
5k display that apple sells on their
website
so i expect the new display panel that
apple is working on
to be identical to the one that's going
into the higher end imac
and because of all this i'd have to
place my bets that the new high-end imac
will have either a 28 inch display or a
29.5 inch display which apple would mark
it as a 30
inch now moving on to the chip situation
i'm now
100 sure that the high-end imac will be
getting
the m1x chip as the only chip option
for a few different reasons first off
the twitter user dylan dkt
has recently confirmed that the high-end
imac will be released next year
and in mark german's recent edition of
his newsletter
he basically agreed to the exact same
thing this totally makes sense because
if you think about it
apple revealed the m1 imac five months
after revealing the
m1 macbooks and it ended up getting the
exact
same channel so apple could end up doing
the same exact thing for the high-end
imac
giving it the same m1x chip that we're
expecting for the 14
and 16 inch macbook pros the second
reason is that dylan believes
that the m1x chip will be going into the
higher end mac mini
the 14 and 16 inch macbook pros and the
higher end imac
which i totally agree with now mark
german says that there's
a chance that it'll be getting the m2x
chip instead
but i don't think so because apple would
be skipping a generation
which is wasted potential because giving
this imac the m1x
will provide a much easier upgrade path
for the next imac refresh
while at the same time keeping the
entire current mac lineup
in line with the same m1 based ip
now on top of that dylan also confirmed
that upcoming apple silicon max
will not feature any kind of discrete
gpu on mac
other than the mac pro so this points to
the imac getting the m1x chip
as the only chip option but of course
apple will likely utilize chip binning
to lower the base price and give users
some upgrade options
similar to what they did with the 24
inch imac except this time around
i expect apple to offer either a 12 core
16 core
or 32 core gpu now finally getting to
the release date
dillon explained that the imac has been
delayed until next year
with the main reason being that apple
doesn't want their devices
to compete for attention and delays in
product releases
have led to this timetable what he means
is that we were initially expecting the
14
and 16 inch m1x macbook pros to come at
wwdc
in june and in that case the imac would
have been released in the fall
but since the macbooks got pushed back
apple is
also pushing back the imac just to
spread out the timetable of releases
because if apple released the m1x
macbook pros mac mini and
imac all at the same time the imac would
be
buried underneath the hype of the
macbook pros because they're obviously
much more popular
due to being portable laptops so apple
is simply going to delay the imac for a
few months
even if they have to sit on a shelf
somewhere just so that the imac can
shine in its own spotlight and this is
even more evidence
that it's packing an m1x chip instead of
a future m2x
now to give you even more evidence mark
german's power on newsletter
shows that apple will just barely hit
their two-year apple silicon transition
target
with the 2022 apple silicon mac pro
getting released at the end of next year
in november
so because of that apple likely doesn't
want to release the larger imac at the
same time as the mac pro
since they'll be competing for attention
so in reality
it kind of has to get released in the
first half of next year
and if we go even further both mark
german and dylan
agree that a redesigned macbook air is
coming next year
with dylan claiming that it's going to
come in the first half
of 2022 with a brand new m2 chip
which i totally agree with and i fully
believe that this new m2 chip
deserves its own apple event and that's
why i'm personally predicting
that the macbook air will be revealed in
march and because of that
i think it makes total sense for the m1x
high-end imac to be released before
that event happens potentially through a
simple press release
since apple has already showed off the
new redesign with the 24 inch imac
and now finally let's finish off with
the pricing
our source believes that the base model
will remain at
or under two thousand dollars which
makes total sense
and in my opinion the price of the imac
fully depends on the price of the
upcoming 14 inch macbook pro
if the 14 inch sticks to the same 1799
dollar price tag then the imac will
match it
but if the 14 inch goes up to 19.99
then the imac will also be priced at
19.99
guaranteed but no more than two thousand
dollars for the base price
for sure so with all that said here's my
full prediction list for the features
and specs
which is definitely subject to change as
more and more leaks and rumors get
released
but for now i'm pretty confident in all
of these details
now if you totally disagree with me then
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below
but if you enjoyed this video go ahead
and click the circle above to subscribe
for more videos like this one definitely
check out one of those two right over
there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video